a brand new poster for the upcoming
Wonder Woman 1984 hit the Internet
earlier this week posted to Twitter by
none other than director patty Jenkins
herself
we can't blame Jenkins for wanting the
world to see the dazzling poster as soon
as possible
in a word it's retro the one sheet
flawlessly captures the aesthetic of the
1980s bursting with every shade of the
neon rainbow that all come together to
form a massive W but it's much more than
just an ultra cool-looking piece of
promotional material this Wonder Woman
1984 poster gives fans their first look
at Diana Prince's brand-new costume
which looks a whole lot like her gold
armor from the DC Comics in the source
material Diana obtains enhanced
abilities when she dons the glimmering
getup she's able to fly withstand
explosions bullets energy blasts and
physical attacks and can utilize the
retractable face plate on her helmet to
breathe from a protected air supply if
her oxygen is low or if the air around
her is unclean that should come in handy
next time she has to breathe the air in
London yeah it's not for everybody in DC
Comics Canon the famous gear and artist
Palace created the gold armor and gifted
it to Diana for use in battles against
incredibly powerful opponents it proved
it's worth and Wonder Woman's fights
against villains like the Living weapon
devastation given that Wonder Woman 1984
sees the titular heroine face off with a
Barbara and Minerva iteration of cheetah
played by Kristen Wiig it makes sense
why she would need new armor she's as
formidable foe as diana has ever gone up
against before a British archaeologist
and wealthy heiress Barbara transformed
into her supervillain alter-ego after
traveling to Africa to visit a tribe led
by a woman with all the force strength
and agility of a cheetah
when Marauders killed a woman a priest
named Shama carries out the conference
of powers from the slain leader to
Barbara the ceremony comes with severe
consequences though as Barbara doesn't
meet all the requirements to be the
perfect host for the cheetah entity as a
human she's overcome with pain as
cheetah she's vicious vile and
bloodthirsty what do you walk cheetah to
cut to you Diana what else we don't yet
know how Wonder Woman will cross paths
with cheetah but once she does there's a
strong chance that their first fight
could leave the Amazonian warrior shaken
she might make a quick trip to that
mascara and seek the aid of Pallas who
could outfit her with the gold armor to
help ensure a win over cheetah in their
next battle
this isn't the only Wonder Woman 1984
media that fans got a glimpse of this
week the spanish-language fan account DC
Universe shared another one sheet for
the sequel as displayed at the 2019
licensing Expo currently taking place in
Las Vegas Nevada though the licensing
Expo poster is certainly a visual treat
it doesn't reveal much in the way of
plot Warner Brothers and DC films have
stayed incredibly tight-lipped about the
long-awaited Wonder Woman sequel
revealing very little about what
adventures the eponymous heroine will
embark on for her second turn on the
silver screen all we truly know about
Wonder Woman 1984 is it's time setting
its villain and that Pedro Pascal will
appear as a mysterious and yet unnamed
politician character Chris Pine will
also return as pilot Steve Trevor
somehow
as for what the movie will be about it's
said to follow Diana experiencing
conflict with the Soviet Union during
the Cold War before going head-to-head
with cheetah but there's no intel on how
everything unfolds as backwards as it
sounds that shouldn't be a cause for
concern
director Jenkins seems to have it all
figured out telling deadline in May that
there's a reason why the film takes
place in 1984 which will connect to the
sequels story and resonate with modern
audiences Jenkins explained all I can
say is that 1984 itself is definitely
very evocative - what's important in
that movie and resonates with right now
I picked 1984 for a very specific reason
it was such an incredible time I feel
like there's something about the excess
of that period of time which is so
linked up to where we are in the world
right now that it's set there for a
reason that's all I can say with Wonder
Woman 1984 nowhere near it's June 2020
launch date and the film's promotional
cycle not kicking off until December
fans sadly must wait a while before they
can feast their eyes on more posters and
first look footage at the film hopefully
the end result is worth the wait check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite films are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]